في تقارير شغله عالم التكنولوجيا
ومستخدميها كمان وبتتكلم عن انه تيك توك
بيدرس فرض رسوم على محتوى معين يعني خلي
مثلا صانع المحتوى عنده محتوى عام لكل
المستخدمين وعنده مقاطع ثانيه هذه يقدر
يشوفها بس اللي دافع وطريقه الدفع بحسب
التقارير بتدرس تيك توك كيف تعملها ممكن
يعملوا رسم شهري يبدا من دولار واحد ويشوف
المستخدم كل المحتوى الحصري هذا او يعمله
رسوم تدفع على كل مقطع حصري بشكل منفصل
طيب ليه تيك توك بيعمل كده
تيك توك تطبيق تواصل دخل عالم التطبيقات
الكبرى ونافسها حتى اللي سبقوه في السوق
من سنين وفجاه تفوق باعداد المستخدمين على
فيسبوك وتويتر وانستجرام وسناب تيك توك
السنه الماضيه حرفيا كان على القمه لانه
ببساطه حتى غطى على جوجل وعدت فتره كان
فيها اكثر موقع بتم زيارته يعني متخيلين
موقع او تطبيق بالتم زيارته اكثر من يعني
هذا شيء مهول طبعا من الاشياء اللي ساعدت
تيك توك جدا جائحه كورونا وحبست الناس
والان المنصه اللي ناجحه كثير لسه ناجحه
بس بتعاني لانه مع رجعه الحياه لطبيعتها
الناس بعدت عن التطبيق شويه اعداد
المستخدمين اليوميين او المستخدمين
اليوميين قلت والمستخدمين الجدد كمان قال
له ومن هنا طلعت بفكره الدفع هذه وهي
للامانه مو فكره جديده في عالم منصات
التواصل يعني يوتيوب عنده خدمه بفلوس
مقابل ميزات معينه وتويتر برضه في ميزات
مقابل فلوس بس يمكن الغريب في موضوع التيك
توك انه هيدفعوا الناس مو مقابل خدمات لكن
بس علشان يشوفوا محتوى خاص وبعدين فرضا
مثلا هذا الشخص دفع وراح نشر الفيديو من
عنده ببلاش وقتها ايش حيسووا التيك توك
ايش حيكونوا استفادوا واصلا تيك توك كيف
راح تزيد عدد المستخدمين اذا فرضت رسوم
التقارير على فكره كمان بتتكلم انه توسع
برنامجها اللي بتدفع من خلاله لصناع
المحتوى عشان يبقوا على المنصه احنا حبينا
نعرف مشاهدينا لو انتم كمستخدمين مستعدين
تدفعوا مقابل محتوى على التيك توك
وسالناكم عبر حساباتنا واجاباتكم جاءت
كالت 95% قالوا لا وخمسه في الميه فقط
مستعدين يدفعوا
ينضملين الخبير التقني بصنع المحتوى عبد
الله الغفيس اهلا فيك معنا عبد الله انت
من اي فئه من ضمن ال 95 اللي قالوا لا ما
راح ندفع ولا الخمسه في الميه اللي لا
يدفعوا ممكن عشان يشوفوا كليب او فيديو
حصري
اهلا ساره لا انا بروح مع الخيار الاول ما
راح ادفع صراحه نعم طيب يعني اذا قد كده
الناس عندها رفض لموضوع الدفع وطريقه كمان
يعني تيك توك بتقول انه على فيديوهات
محدده ليش ممكن تيك توك برايك تعمل خطوه
من هذا النوع
هو لو نرجع شويه يعني او نتكلم عن الشبكات
الاجتماعيه بشكل عام الشبكات الاجتماعيه
عندها هدفين الاول انه زادت الايرادات
ورقم اثنين اني ازيد وانمي عدد المستخدمين
وتكتب يعني مثل ما تفضلتي بالتقرير انها
كانت وصلت يعني الى ارقام كبيره من بدات
تعاني من بعض الانخفاضات فهذه احد الحلول
اللي قاعده تسويها تيك توك انه تبغى تجذب
عدد اكبر تبغى تفاعل يعني حتى لما شفت
التقرير اللي طلع انه هذه الفكره ممكن
انها تجذب يعني تفاعل اكثر فبتخلي
المستخدمين يقولون وقت يعني اطول على تيك
توك بس كيف حتعمل تفاعل اكتر يعني فكره
اني انا ادفع عشان محتوى معين ليش حتخليني
يعني اتفاعل بشكل اكبر بعدين تيك توك
بيطلعوا فلوس بالهبل من الاعلانات اللي هل
كان على التطبيق يعني
صحيح هي طبعا الفكره انه فائده للطرفين
فائده اللي هو الصانع المحتوى وفائده الى
يعني الى نفس الشركه
ممكن يبتكرون طرق معينه ممكن اني اضع هذا
الفيديو يعني ما يظهر الا اذا دفعت ممكن
يكون كانه مشاهده مثلا مبكره مثل الافلام
او غيرها من الاعلانات نشاهدها الان ثم
بعد فتره بتتحول الى مجاني في امور كثيره
ممكن انه نعرفها لما يتم اطلاق الخدمه
بشكل رسمي يعني انت بتقول انه هذه او هذا
الشيء حتعملوا تيك توك بالتعاون غالبا مع
صناع المحتوى فالفكره كمان انه يفيدوا او
يزيدوا الفائده لصناع المحتوى عشان ينتجوا
اكثر يعني
صحيح هو هذا الهدف انه زياده اكثر او دخل
اكثر او صناع المحتوى ممكن حتى انه نشوف
ناس مثلا تستخدمه بالتحديات او البثوث
اللي موجوده الان نروح مثلا افتح المقطع
الموجود علشان تشوف الفكره ما ادري يعني
اكيد انه بنشوف افكار يعني كثيره وقتها
صحيح طيب تعتقد كمان موضوع انه الدفع على
كل فيديو الحال يعني منطقي ولا لازم
الموضوع يصير اشتراك شهري يعني تجربه
يوتيوب وتجربه تويتر اشتراكات شهريه حتى
لما بنتكلم عن منصات كبيره مثلا يعني شاهد
نتفليكس عندهم اشتراكات حصريه برضو بتدفع
زياده وبتاخد اشياء حصريه بس موضوع فيديو
هذا مو غريب
هو ممكن يكون انه غريب يعني في منصه ثانيه
لكن اعتقد المستخدمين الخاصين بتيك توك
مثلا احنا شايفين انه يشترون الهدايا
الرقميه ويدفعون فاعتقد ان الطريقه بتكون
قريبه منها مثلا الموضوع مو غريب يعني على
يوتيوب شفنا على تويتر ببعض الحسابات اللي
ما تنشر اخبار الا عند الاشتراك او ما
تنشر محتوى الا من خلال الاشتراك فاعتقد
ممكن انه يصير بنفس الفكره وممكن بعد فتره
يعني انها تحسن فتكتوك الان قاعده اتحسن
يعني كل فتره شفنا قبل فتره لما اعلنوا عن
موضوع التجاره الالكترونيه وكيف انهم
دمجوها داخل التطبيق والان هذه الفكره
فكلها امور حابين انهم يزودوا الايرادات
كذلك ينمون عدد المستخدمين بس انا مثلا
لما يعني ادخل والمفروض انه انا افتح حساب
وكمان ادفع فلوس صراحه ما راح اشترك في
المنصه يعني في نهايه اليوم يعني خلاص
الواحد اشتكى من كثره التطبيقات والاشياء
اللي جالس بيدفعها يعني فهم كيف انهم
حيزيدوا التطبيق خاصه لو احنا شفنا الناس
بتقول ما عندهم استعداد يدفعوا
هي بالاخير بتكون موضوع اختياري وهذه هنا
بنرجع الى شطاره مثلا صناع المحتوى او
كذلك شطاره التطبيق كيف انه بخليه اكبر
ممكن تيجي رده فعل عكسيه صح صحيح ممكن
وحتى انا شفت اليوم يعني تعليقات ناس كثير
بتويتر كان اللي يقول بحذف التطبيق وما
ادري ايش ما راح استخدمه ففعلا ممكن انهم
يفقدون عدد اكبر
هنا وقت قعدت تصير ازمه ويصير في تراجع
ونشوف الموضوع طيب نحن بنشكرك على هذه
المداخله كان معنا الخبير التقني وصانع
المحتوى عبد الله شكرا لك عبد الله